today we're going to be speaking with
nicole pearl roth who's an award-winning
cyber security journalist for the new
york times and also author of this is
how they tell me the world ends the
cyber weapons arms race
it's so great to have you on i
appreciate it thanks so much for having
me david
so let let's just start kind of at the
top level i think
a lot of people who are aware of a cyber
threat and about the
priority that this has become for so
many governments may not really
understand
what a cyber attack might actually mean
sort of for the average person you might
have a vague idea about
could you shut down a water system for
example or paralyze
an electricity grid or something like
that what do we mean by cyber attack
what are the types of things that
could be done so for a long time
people's real experience with cyber
attacks
was really just the theft of their
personal data or maybe their credit card
information
and there was no real repercussions
there you know you might have to deal
with identity theft if it got really
gnarly
but for the most part your bank would
probably pay you back
if if any money was stolen from your
account or credit card information that
kind of thing
the problem is that these days we have
rolled so much software
into our critical infrastructure like
the power grid
like our nuclear plants like our water
treatment facilities and wastewater
treatment plants
that all of that those access points
can be the target for a cyber attack and
in fact we are seeing
every year more nation-state hackers but
also low-level
cyber criminals target these systems and
so the attack that we really fear
uh would be an attack that took out
power and potentially contaminated the
water and actually it would look
a lot like what we just witnessed in
texas
a few weeks ago when the power went out
um you know the water supply was
contaminated
and in the event of a cyber attack which
you could use cyber means to
take out the power and contaminate the
water and we've seen russia do that in
ukraine and
we just saw an attempt to contaminate
the water supply in a small town in
florida the other week
fortunately it was caught but the
problem is with the cyber attack there's
also the possibility
that hackers could keep those systems
down
and when we've run studies here in the
united states to see
how resilient our critical
infrastructure is to a cyber attack
some of those simulations have showed
that it could be years before
people were able to bring those systems
back online so i think we're a little
bit better than we were when those
simulations were done but there's a real
threat
of a cyber attack on on the grid
so when it comes to the kind of identity
theft credit card theft stuff that many
of us have dealt with all of a sudden
i had a period where like uber and door
dash charges were showing up on my
credit card
and you know the annoyance type stuff it
seems the motivation of the individual
is basically to get free stuff to get a
free
uh free takeout or a free uber ride or
whatever the case may be
when we start talking about things like
shutting down a power grid contaminating
water etc
it see correct me if i'm wrong it seems
we're talking about a fork that is more
malicious for the sake of being
malicious of making a political point of
of making an attack that may be more
against an institution or a country or
an organization
are those these two forks in terms of
motivations or is it more complicated
than that
well i think you're right i mean a lot
of the attacks we have seen
on critical infrastructure has been
messaging um
when russia shut off the power in
ukraine
first in 2015 and then in 2016
they only did it for a few hours and i
really believe that that was to send a
message
uh to sort of see doubt in ukrainian's
mind
that their new government had things
under control
you know it was really political
messaging and sort of hanging this
threat
over the population that russia could
turn off the power at the flip of a
switch
other attacks have had different
motivations we caught iran
rifling around the controls at a dam in
the united states
fortunately it was the wrong dam we have
two bowman dams
one of them holds back a tsunami's worth
of water in
oregon and the other holds back a
babbling brook in
new york and they got into the one that
holds back a babbling brook and it was
under repair so it wasn't an actual
threat
but you know who knows what the message
was there
i think it was probably just some sort
of experimentation to see if they could
get into these systems
in case they needed to one day you know
unleash
the locks at that dam um and that's more
of what we're starting to see we're
starting to see
nation state hackers get into these
critical infrastructure systems
not necessarily because they want to do
something immediately
but because we're all planning for some
kind of geopolitical trigger
where we might need to be in a position
to turn off the lights or unleash the
locks at a dam or contaminate the water
supply
but you know each of these attacks
essentially enshrines critical
infrastructure as a legitimate target
for a cyber attack and at the end of the
day it's civilian populations
who would suffer the results of those
attacks so it's yeah
more dangerous this so this is one of my
questions about how this fits into
warfare more broadly because you know
one of the things that's happened over
the last 10 to 15 years is
we we've heard more about and it
actually has moved in the direction of
the idea of a war that's like a boots on
the ground war the likes of which
you know certainly the first gulf war to
a degree
the 2003 iraq war things are moving away
from that drone warfare is certainly
part of it but also so is cyber warfare
but a foreign power for example shutting
off electricity in a large part of the
united states
we understand the chaos that it will
create we understand the damage it can
do
but how would it fit into a broader war
in the sense of what would it be part of
trying to accomplish for the foreign
power that does it
i i'm guessing it's not shut the power
off so they can
steal florida from us and make it part
of some other country there must be
what would be the goal or how would it
fit in yeah it's a really good question
and it's an important question because
you don't want to over hype
the threat right but it is the reality
that russia has been targeting our grid
for several years now a few years ago
the department of homeland security
published a screenshot that literally
showed russian hackers inside
our power plants with their fingers on
the switches that could turn off the
lights
so we know that they have gotten into
these systems which begs the question
what are they doing there you know at
what point will they see some kind of
incentive or motivation to turn off the
lights
right i do think that this is all
battlefield preparation for some
future event whether it's you know a
declaration of war
and this would be one element of that
warfare
turning off the lights or shutting off
the communication systems
in the event that geopolitical tensions
got so
heated that one of these countries felt
the need to do so
we have been hacking into russia's grid
i broke that story with my colleague
david singer a couple years ago
partly as retaliation somewhat for the
election but also for russia's acts and
incursions of our own grid
but we've been doing it more as mutually
assured destruction
i was going to say yeah i was going to
say it reminds me of like
during nuclear weapon development a lot
of people say
what is the circumstance where we would
ever use even 10 of these nukes like
what is that situation and it becomes
this conversation of well you know
if they did it we would we would need to
be in a position to do it and being in a
position to do it would disincentivize
them from doing it
it it has a sort of similar feel as you
mentioned that
yes it is our attempt at mutually
assured destruction
in the digital age the problem is that
nuclear analogies really don't fit so
neatly in cyber um you know for one
this is all code right we're attacking
these systems with code
um there's a low barrier to entry
uh you know if we hack a system it is
entirely possible for that attack to be
discovered
uh for those methods to be discovered
for that code to be picked up
and reverse engineered and retrofitted
and used back on
us and in cyber what we've noticed over
the last 10 years is that
people learn a lot from their adversary
you know we
pulled off an attack with israel on
iran's nuclear plant
where we broke into their nuclear
facility natan's nuclear facility
we dispatched code that jumped from
their microsoft windows systems
into their industrial controllers and we
eventually used that code to spin their
uranium centrifuges
out of control or slowed them down and
we ultimately destroyed
a thousand of their centrifuges no one
has pulled off a cyber attack
that level of sophistication since but
um you know what our adversaries have
learned is they don't need to have the
sophistication
of that attack to do damage a couple
years after that attack
we saw iran hit saudi aramco world's
largest oil company saudi arabia
right with an attack that just used
rudimentary code to
wipe out the data on their systems and
replace it with an image of a burning
american flag
and so we're all sort of learning after
each other and
each attack has sort of build off the
capabilities of the last and
unlike nuclear where you need fissile
material to drop a bomb
right in cyber you just need a laptop
and someone with the skills
and increasingly you can purchase those
skills
and code and capabilities off a gray
market
so it's really unregulated space um
it is getting more and more dangerous
particularly as we digitize more of our
infrastructure
and the thing i think people don't
realize is that you know america
might still be the greatest offensive
player in this realm
like i said no one has pulled off
anything close to the attack we pulled
off on iran
more than 10 years ago but we are also
the most targeted we have
more nation states and cyber criminals
lined up at our borders at our systems
knocking on the door getting in in a lot
of cases and planting back doors
and we're the most vulnerable in a lot
of cases because we are so
wired much more so than adversaries like
north korea and iran etc
so on that note i mean in the limited
time we have left
the reaction of some might be well we've
got to pull all of our we
have to go backwards technologically we
have to get a lot of stuff that's
currently networked off of networks uh
silo things etc in in most instances
that's
that's not really a solution to problems
would it be the wrong
the wrong reaction to this no i mean i
think we do
need to step back and think harder about
the defense of these systems eighty
percent
of america's critical infrastructure is
owned and maintained by private
companies and any attempt
to sort of legislate that they have
better security
um has has always failed lobbyists have
always watered it down so any
attempt to secure our critical
infrastructures come in the form of an
executive order
first under obama and then there was one
under trump
but really you know these are all just
setting voluntary
standards for these critical
infrastructure owners to up their
security and
unfortunately a lot of these systems are
owned by small medium-sized businesses
local municipal systems
that simply don't have the security
budgets or resources of a pg
e say here in california so they have to
rely on this outside network of
contractors and supervisors
and the fact that they have to let those
people in remotely creates an
opportunity for hackers so what do we do
you know if we're not going to legislate
that these companies have to up their
security what do you do and i think
one of the things that we need to start
talking about is
creating better market incentives for
these companies to up their security
you know giving tax credits maybe to
companies who
use two-factor authentication and have
all of their software up to date and
pass with flying colors on a penetration
testing
exam um or perhaps it's time to exact
penalties on companies who are not
updating and patching their systems and
allowing anyone to remote in
so i do actually think it's a really
important question to ask ourselves okay
if we're not going to let the government
into these private systems
if we're going to rely on the market
well the market
has always led us down a path of further
vulnerability because
security has no return return on
investment
yeah it's the deep water horizon the 500
000
valve that if you install it everywhere
you protect but it's unlikely you'll
need it everywhere and then they install
it nowhere at all that's such a great
analogy
i hadn't thought of that but that is the
perfect analogy and so we really need to
have these conversations around
how to lock up these systems and
you know there's been some conversations
about should we have a digital geneva
convention
should we set some kind of international
norms of behavior
where we would agree not to hack
russia's power grid and they would agree
not to hack ours or hospitals or
elections
the problem is we the united states will
never agree
to those norms because one
we are still we still have a huge
offensive advantage
but also too we don't trust that our
adversaries would hold to those
agreements
because they outsource many of their
attacks
to cyber criminals to
contractors and front companies the
attacks that we conduct
out of the united states come out of the
pentagon cyber command or maybe the nsa
if it's espionage or the other
intelligence agencies
we don't rely on some you know security
engineer at google and tap them on the
shoulder at night and say tonight you're
working with us
we just don't have that ability or
plausible deniability so we worry that
if we ever agree to these norms
that these other countries would just
sort of say well we won't do it
but they would outsource those attacks
right we
don't we don't really want to commit not
to doing it and we wouldn't believe that
their commitment would be would be
trustworthy
they may believe the exact same about us
as well and it makes it a very
complicated uh
situation we've been speaking with
nicole pearl roth
who is a cyber security journalist for
the new york times the book is this is
how they tell me the world ends the
cyber weapons arms race
nicole really appreciate your time today
thank you so much for having me